it's [ __ ] ironic when a white
feminist lesbian protect Moses to
protect the burqa hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Frances Foster i'm
konstantine kisser
and this is a show for you if you're
bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about the trigonometry we don't pretend
to be the experts we ask the experts are
brilliant guests this week is a writer
and activist named Carly welcome to
trigonometry hi thank you having me
[Music]
listen before we get into the interview
itself for anyone who doesn't know who
you are you obviously very well known
for your work on FGM and we'll get into
that yeah but just tell us who are you
how are you where you are what has
brought you to this chair where you said
no you sent me a message on Twitter
saying I'm an anti FGM activist and
ultimately I think the trajectory of my
career changed when I realized that my
silence was very much complicit to the
misunderstanding of the form of violence
that I was subjected to when I was seven
so I went to university I'm actually
qualified I did you know but I'm also
spend most of my time talking about the
female anatomy so I call myself myself
the chief funny defender so that's what
I do I basically just sit around and
politically and socially work towards
and then a specific form of violence and
we'll get into that as I said later on
than into one of the reasons we wanted
to have you on is obviously to talk
about that because it's an important
issue and Frances you know you're a
former teacher you had some experiences
with that right yeah I used to work in
you yeah so I've seen oh I never saw it
happened whatever of course not but I
know I saw girls disappear yeah and then
come back a few months later and the
change in it and obviously we never knew
yeah because we'll get into that about
how nobody has ever been prosecuted or
charged with no there has been a
successful prosecution the cps who are
the bane of every woman's life have just
actually decided to update their
guidance to kind of make it easier for
people to get away with it
with FGM but there was a successful
prosecution this year oh wow that's it
because the last time I checked when we
were when I went to training not a
couple of years ago they were saying
that nobody'd ever yeah so they've never
had a success so that they had quite
quite a few prosecutions this and last
year and in April there was those that
there was a woman ironically from
Walthamstow so around that kind of area
that was sentenced and for performing
FGM on her and three-year-old child you
know what we've got into it when he was
saying oh we will we'll talk about that
I can at the end like since the age of
seven FGM has been the fundamental thing
has actually shaped my reality and also
shared my political views so in terms of
even like you know the way that I talk
and what I do a lot of that has been
fundamentally around the way that I was
misunderstood as somebody that came from
a community I was affected by EF here
but then also I was more than that so
yeah it's a it's like an let's dive into
a quote let's dive into it no no battle
plan survives it's a very contentious
issue it's a very difficult issue for a
lot of people it's something that I also
think there's a lot of misconceptions
about yeah so just just to be start us
off by explaining to people who may not
know anything about it yeah
what is FGM female genital mutilation a
lot of people think always a bit like
circumcision everybody does it it's it's
a different culture some people think
it's it's to do with this line which
like just debunk a few other things for
us so basically the fundamental are the
cool thing is that FGM is injury or
damage or removal of any of the female
anatomy for non-medical reasoning and I
think that's the key thing it's the fact
that it's for non-medical reasons and a
lot of people want to kind of pop
culture I want to put like faith and all
these things in there but it's a form of
violence and one of the key things that
I was that I was saying about why the
CPS is new definition of saying that if
it if it's done in a hospital out of
women of a certain age then the consent
can really apply into that is that it's
a form of GBH it's like when we took a
mutilation it's the body being changed
from its natural settings for no reason
at all and we would not accept that if
you said to me right now do you know
what I can send you to chop off my hands
I would get arrested because that's gph
as a corrosion of society that if we are
starting to give people consent to cause
massive damage but when it comes to the
female anatomy and the women's bodies we
are constantly talking about as though
that there's no kind of influence on
doing these things I'm telling you no
girl will ever walk where wake up and
say do you know what I'm really not
happy with my Anatomy I want it to be I
want it to be cut and I remember
watching an episode of the play girls
the paper I know it was it was what was
he going like that and you have Hugh
Hefner's you haven't had a show on a me
child at a channel I was quite young I
was watching this show and the Playboy
Bunnies or the girlfriends I had again
that was a form of abuse the fact that
polygamy is like [ __ ] ridiculous but
they were talking about labiaplasty
which is like cosmetic surgery on the
female anatomy and then I was and then
my mum was like well why would they do
that to themselves and I said but why
would you do FGM to yourself remember
why would you do after me to girls like
me and it's this whole idea of the fact
that but that's my culture or I've
basically chosen to do this the
patriarchy is powerful and what we do is
is the more we empower women the more it
comes back in other places so FGM is
literally like you know any damage to
the female anatomy it doesn't matter
whether you're three years old or
whether you're like 25 there's no
medical reasons for it and all of it
legitimizes other forms of abuse to
women so so what you're saying is
incredibly enlightening
then the begs a question why do it why
do you sold some cultures have FGM so
the same so it's because it's every
single woman in my family until about
the 2005 had been had we had undergone
FGM so there was this assumption of what
it was like to be a Somali woman and
culture is a weird thing which we're all
gripped in like you know if we're the
way that I'm dressed today or the way
that your address or what you think or
you believe in are all informed by the
way that we're raising the people that
were around and if you don't have
anybody else telling you that you
shouldn't be doing this then you just
keep they and then you're gonna keep
doing it and you're gonna make it as a
fundamental thing to who makes you who
you are and to take something like FGM
away that's basically being what my
grandmother my great
my mother everybody had them for me to
say but it's really stupid like why are
we doing this
that is judging people that is like you
know shaking people's real core values
and for me I never knew FGM was abuse I
just thought I knew is painful and I
just knew was really stupid and asking
questions as to but why are you doing it
or to my nan Somali community and
friends saying to my teachers like why
is this happening to me
and people having no answers around
there made me really understand that
actually this was something that nobody
understood and they were doing it
because they were scared of not doing it
and that my teachers who were all
English were scared of intervening
because they didn't know what was
actually going on so a lot of it's all
about control and that the patriarchy
you will enforce things on women in
order to keep them down so yeah it's
just like why does anything happen like
any of the things that we want to kind
of evolve and change is because some
evil people are benefiting from it I'm
guessing the question people might ask
in a circumcision or the male
circumcision exists it's obviously a
different thing and it's much less
invasive and whatever but you know some
of the arguments for Jewish people like
Maya some of my ancestors and Arabic
people living in the desert the argument
was that it's about hygiene if you get
sand stuck under your for ski like yeah
1400 years ago but this is like - so I
said to one of my friends was the way
circumcising your child is like it's
more hygienic I said by the soap and
water and she's like for sex or like
he's eight days old yeah why are we
thinking about who he's having sex with
yeah and I always think and I'm gonna
get a lot of this is I think this is the
thing that can unite like you know the
Middle East Polk tuition was for him
is around male circumcision and I'm
gonna get a lot of [ __ ] for this but
ultimately if you took out religion and
said like why you cut in a healthy
tissue of a young baby boy who you just
would immunize in a few days not to get
like you know tetanus and all these
other kind of things and then you said
well a few thousand years ago this man
was hallucinating he was a prophet
though let me tell you this was a man
that God was speaking to he God was
speaking to him God said to him murder
your first child and then he said
actually I'm not gonna do that but I'm
gonna do it and then he was
so obedience the son into alarm and to
be so grateful he pulled his penis out
and cut some skin off it that's why 4000
years later and I'm doing this to my
child in in crotch ends yes yeah no I
agree
I guess you mentioned the patriarchy
several times I was just thinking like
it happens to boys as well I'm that
probably wasn't the patriarchy was what
people four thousand years ago in the
desert believed right no but the thing
about so the difference or the
fundamental difference between male
circumcision and FGM so one I don't
support any for surgery on children but
ultimately what happens is the FGM where
FGM is prominent and where shame is
practice there is like you know other
forms of gender-based violence where men
have their foreskin removed again the
keys to the kingdom they're not being
forced to be married they're not being
stopped from going certain employment
they're not being segregated so they're
not being forced to wear the burka or
there's several other things that happen
as a result of where FGM is evident so
so the life the life consequences
physically is well physical the
physicality is another thing as well
that like even the most that the least
invasive form of FGM which is the
unheard in or clitoridectomy moving the
external parts of the clitoris on a male
organ would mean like removing almost
like the total penis so the physicality
the physical impacts are different the
social and emotional impacts that happen
in there are different as well so I
think that's the fundamental thing it's
like how the society structured and to
be fair there is a little bit of male
ego involved in male circumcision that
fathers always want their sons to look
like them that's one of the main reasons
why a lot of like you know a lot of and
also Jewish and Muslim mothers want like
you know other women to be very proud of
what their baby's penis looks like I
just think is that why are we talking
about like this is quite pedophilic it's
like that we're all standing here
staring our baby's penis it's a bit
weird like take religion out of it it's
very weird and FGM from what I got told
and please correct me if this is wrong
a large part of that is control over
women and their pleasure of having sex
well it's it's more it's more about
control over women I get an ownership
so pleasure so I wrote a book recently
called things were told not to talk
about but we're going to anyway and the
heart of that was the conversation
around the female orgasm nobody ever
talks about female pleasure
so female pleasure is always seen as a
bonus not as a right in terms of sexual
relationships no in my house I think
that's like you know that is
fundamentally the thing is the fact that
it's not like you know it's not about
control but it's the whole thing all
right well obviously the reason why you
can't have an orgasm is because of the
fact that you'd be mutilating it's not
but it's it's it's it's because the fact
that you're being oppressed and rape on
a day to day basis when I don't know
those women don't even have any choice
over the men that they marry so
technically if you're being forced to
sleep with somebody every night it's
rape because you never chose to marry
him and to be in that relationship so
there is an element of control about the
ownership of sexual pleasure as opposed
to control zone like sexual pleasure
only sits within the male like you know
a member of the relationship so the idea
of removing the clitoris is that there's
no need for you to be sexually pleased
you're only there to have children all
right I was gonna ask you you mentioned
culture and religion
yeah and there was a cup there was a
couple of things that I asked you at the
top I just want to clarify so for anyone
who doesn't know first of all where is
FGM normally practice so you're from
Somaliland yourself yeah is it mainly
Africa is it beyond that
where are the regions where this is part
of the local context in terms of the
largest number of countries on a
continent Africa is the largest was it
has 28 countries and have more than a 40
percent I've taken appreciate mothers
like Indonesia and like you know parts
of India and I would actually classify
harlotry procedures called cosmetic
surgery on the funeral to me as FGM so
it's a global issue in terms of how we
diviner whether it's a razor or whether
it's happened in the huts or in a
hospital it's all exactly the same but
ultimately in places where I eat
Ethiopia for example where has like you
know Christians Jews Muslims and non
and people of the book religions FGM II
is practiced there so bye-bye even by
Jews and by Christopher it's a cultural
issue I thought so therefore it's a
Ethiopian thing so it's repair hazard
after issue so yeah and also it predates
all the kind of the Abrahamic religions
so it's 4,000 years old so it's like it
was well before my hamon well before
Moses and well before Christ as well
because that's one of the big I think
misunderstanding certainly in this
country when people talk about it I
think a lot of people think that it's a
Muslim because because of the fact that
we've called the circumcision and then
what happened was so that the technology
was female circumcision which was wrong
cause it's FGM and then what happened
was that the circumcision started within
the Jewish community or within the
Muslim community and because there was
no evidence within the Jewish community
of FGM that people are see because it
was called circumcision it must come
from Muslim backgrounds so I just got
out yeah so it must have just come from
a Muslim background but it doesn't like
you know I've known people from all
faiths and no faith so I've actually
practiced FGM it's a bit like rape and
domestic violence it I don't know it
crosses the the series of the books and
what are the long-term health
implications for if for these women who
have had this procedure I think like the
main thing is death it's like there's
like the like the cod look alike you
know FGM can kill and we always say
survivors of FGM so there are millions
of women and those who haven't survived
and I think the complications go go and
go into
dependence on the physicality of the FGM
that you had so I had a really invasive
form of FGM and when I was 11 my kidneys
almost failed and I almost died so they
were so type 3 which is in fibrillation
which is more common in Egypt Somalia
and Sudan Somalia in all those places is
where they basically
stitch the female anatomy together and
that means that if these girls are being
cut as young as 7 like I was you go into
puberty with no ability to men straight
like you know helpfully urinate
freely and also if you do have sex like
getting penetrated through like some raw
to like you know some
you know scar tissue it's going to be
extremely painful and then pregnancy so
there are massive complications that
kind of come into it rather than the
social and the psychological impacts of
FGM are fundamental where you're
subjecting something so horrific and
brutal and needless to a child and that
will have lifelong complications and I
think we have had this view of not never
assuming what the emotional consequences
could be all the emotional that I cannot
the feelings the African women have we
never talked about so we know Africa
many countries in Africa have been at
war for four decades but we never talk
about the realities of what like you
know what it means to be a woman in
Africa living with such brutality we
just assume as a physical act that we're
gonna ultimately just fix so for me I
think the emotional psychological issues
are more fundamental than the
physicality was which we focus on and do
you think we're doing enough in this
country to deal with it in these
particular communities or are you know
the powers that be sensitive about doing
because accusing of being intolerant to
being racist of all the rest of it
actually sorry before you answer that
question was a great question can you
tell us how prominent is in the UK so so
within the UK there are 137 thousand
women died living with the consequence
of FGM Wow and in 2000 and in them just
about and five or six years ago when we
did some data one in ten births in
Southwark was born to a woman who had
FGM hmm I know so it's a massive issue
it's a huge issue it's a huge issue but
the McKenney also shows you that who are
having babies within this car within the
country at the moment it's like the
large families are within families with
FGM and all these things are practiced
because of poverty and the fact that
women don't have any control over their
body so obviously the ideally and these
women are constantly giving birth which
is another kind of massive issue that we
thought we should be talking about so to
come back to Francis question now part
of which was why is it do you think
we're doing enough number one and also
why is it that we may be reluctant to
talk about it I think we also the since
the coalition government came in in 2010
and
there has a lot has changed and really
weirdly enough on Tuesday I was with
four secretary state of state so so
pretty Patera the home office guy Kevin
Williamson education my Hancock and
health and then another Rob I have great
standing and from communities and all
for secretary of says were committed to
talking about FGM so those are the
various incredible things that are
happening and I do think that I can I do
know that a girl so my niece is eight
years old now
she is a hundred percent safer from FGM
than I could have ever been when I was
her age and there are like you know
things that have been input and put in
place in order to make sure that her
rights are respected for ultimately
those people that want to continue
action we will keep will will keep
pushing and I think the decision I was
talking about the CPS today it's
problematic because at this moment in
time there are people in Kenya who were
trying to revoke the law against FGM
saying well fine but FGM for children
but let women have choices around this
issue and there is like this idea of
choice doesn't actually like you know
exist and I think we have to understand
the commonality of what the legislation
and what does protecting civil rights
and protecting human rights of women
really mean and that means that certain
things are just unacceptable we don't
have like your you can't say well if I
consent to being beaten by my by my
husband then that's fine we understand
that's coercion and it is abuse and it's
grooming within those issues we don't
accept that if you've been in a
relationship where rape and domestic
violence has happened that even though
you say this because I'm kind of consent
given so we have to understand that
there is no consent when it comes to a
form of violence against women and girls
and not for me I find that really
problematic when people try to
intellectualize say oh well well it's
not like this girl in Africa that's
being held down I said actually at least
you can see the horrors of that girl
fighting back before you to willingly
walk into a clinic and be subjected to
the same act of violence that I was and
consume that as empowering I think
that's more problematic for me and that
is the kind of conversations that we
need to be having that it doesn't matter
and also the FGM legislation is
ridiculous here
says a girl should include women and FGM
should not be allowed for cultural
reasoning and then the cultures defined
as the 20 African countries so if I go
too hard shoot and say I'm Caribbean and
I want type 1 FGM that's fine if I say
I'm Somali and I want type 1 FGM I don't
have any concept of choice so then I'm
stopped from having that alright that is
how the legislation sits at the moment
that that black we move from African
heritage can't make choices but other
women come there's a very weird thing
particularly with the trans
conversations happening now isn't it
because a trans person can say well I
identify as different gender and fy1 so
medical necessity and I and I think you
have to have like medical so like the
whole the whole idea of cancer so there
is it's a bit like abortion abortion is
not actually a right here in the cut in
the UK you have a legitimate defense to
asking for an abortion because two
doctors define it to be medically
necessary for your physical or emotional
well-being and they don't people forget
that say another factor but that the
abortion act is a defense to the act of
abortion as opposed to a right to have
an abortion and that's what there is
that caviar that's built into the FGM
legislation where if you need this so if
example I had aware so had like an
evolved a cancer all these things there
will be a need to mutilate my anatomy to
save my life if I had like you know if I
was going through gender reassignment
there would be a medical and a
psychological need to mutilate my
anatomy it doesn't take away from the
fact that what's happening to you it's
an act of FGM but there's a legitimate
legal reason for that right and that's
what people just don't understand here
but to go in and say oh I just don't
like I just don't like my flaps you just
walk in says don't like my flat yeah
yeah yeah yeah
no no absolutely and when these girls
and young girls I mean how does it I got
told that a lot at the time they you
know they got taken back to places like
Somalia or these countries and then the
operations happened there and then they
got brought back is it happening in all
people doing this sort of a backstreet
like an abortion and so there was
evidence when I was growing up in the
80s and early 90s that was happening
here in the UK but now parents are
taking their girls away because at least
that way when you're kind of trying to
groom and brainwash them into the whole
idea you're kind of taking them back to
a culture which they've longed for so
then if therefore they see mrs. parlo so
a lot of that a lot of the FGM is now
extraterritorial and that's why the 2003
legislation made illegal for girls to be
taken out of the UK to be cut but but
then there are women that are turning up
at clinics or FGM you know in the in
giving birth who haven't left the
country who's been refitted again
stitching women back up because what
happens is a lot of these women some of
them might come to join husbands here
the FGM has happened before they became
a British residents but they're 4f
Jeremy something still the NHS has to
deal with and that woman is deemed
fibrillated so basically her nothing was
opened up in order to give birth and
then she comes back again with similar
like you know issues that that she had
before
meaning that FGM has happened somewhere
here in the UK but ultimately there are
people the last the last case which was
unsuccessful was a 16 year old girl
who's whose Anatomy had shown up as
being Sam injured and being mutilated
but the court just didn't believe that
her father who she said well it was the
person who initiated the f chairman can
I can Oh was sanctioned there was the
person that did that but that girl still
was mutilated here in the UK this weird
allowance yeah with some of the broader
issues around this and many other things
that you've talked and written about one
of the things I think Frances you
brought up earlier was this idea that
there's a kind of cultural relativism
that happens with teen so always just
that culture you know this is how they
do things you know just let them do
their thing we who are we to tell people
in Somalia how to live their life right
that's an argument that comes from a
certain section particularly I think of
the left yeah what do you make of that
well it's it's it's [ __ ] it's just
basically like you know throwing you to
the wolves so it's like well them cause
that's fine you're like love you you
should be really British buck
let's just like let's just put a
pretextual and he were right sorry
and I think that's one of the things
we're in in April we had FGM added to
the Children's Act where it was before
so like there's like if if a social
worker a teacher other people are
concerned that a child could be in
danger or neglect it was basically the
ability to get a protection order was
there but FGM was an antigen so it was
you had to prove the level of negligence
or harm that was going to be caused to
the child but if these family so like
there are no there are no other
indicators of abuse within a lot of
these families so that so that's what
people say a loving family so these kids
are well fed that like you know they're
clean they're not turning up at school
like you know late they're basically in
what looks like decent families which my
family would look like from the outside
as opposed to just being an FG on
practicing community so there's no
triggers for social services other
people to get together a protection
order or to limit the parental rights of
these parents and the FGM needed to be
added to that because I think because
because what what these social workers
that people were saying yes I know she's
cleanly dressed she's being fed but
there's a risk of FGM and that just
wasn't in the Children's Act so we ended
up so there was an incredible member of
the House of Lords who I kind of like
this up it came through it was sponsored
by two conservative MPs and then just on
the second reading that great [ __ ]
and Christopher chops objected to it
saying well we were first was singling
and I mean it's really it's really
interesting the left who are so woke and
these and and some like you know really
old school like you know I want to be
like you know having black people bring
me food and stuff like that like you
know on the right I want to bring the
Empire back to a certain exam like in
the sense of like let's keep the culture
we should intervene and he objected and
thankfully the the the the government
KKK have a time and over rolled and like
you know overruled here but what was
really interesting was a conversation I
was having with people
this key thing says let me play the
devil's advocate like the devil doesn't
need a [ __ ] out of a guy like have
you not read everything that's in the
Quran and the Torah and the Bible and
everything else like you know like the
devil doesn't need anybody to advocate
on his side but they were Olympians
divided it's like you know why should we
intervene and I said it's really
interesting that if there was evidence
of your daughter so it's this white guy
if your daughter if you were subjecting
your daughter to FGM all the idea that
they even was talked about like you know
people come down here like like a ton of
bricks but if my daughter is that the
same risk because she's brown which she
just basically respected me people agree
P before we respect her and say oh I
didn't really think of that I said and
if my daughter or a daughter god that
looked like me was adopted by white
parents that she's okay to be protective
but not be protecting when she's behind
communities which are non-whites it's
this whole thing that we're saying that
the human rights of certain people have
more legitimacy than others and it's not
like we're not saying that these kids
shouldn't be vaccinated was in at these
kids should be protected from Ike you
know torture which is actually defined
by the UN so yeah a lot of it for me
it's actually quite and it's offensive
and it's hurtful and it actually shows a
lot of racism in the sense that they
clearly just saying that my rights don't
matter and me being subjected to a
horrific form of abuse it's fine because
that's what savages do difficult yet
this is it like there that's what
savages to like like we don't evolve and
then Co do you think as well it's a lot
of it it is racism are great and a lot
of it is cowardice as well because you
see it from the modern feminist movement
where they want to know tear down the
patriarchy but when it comes to an issue
like FGM which is a massive issue in
like you said it affects over a hundred
thousand women in this country do they
want to get involved or they just sort
of backed away from it well it depends
like you know like you know a radical
feminism has always been quite friendly
and it's kind of supported I think one
of the kind of the key interest was when
I first started doing the work was the
conversations around black feminism
black working class feminism here in the
UK and I think on that when that was
very much embedded within the labor
movement and I think that's very
problematic in the
I think you see your race before you see
a gender and for me I've always been a
woman before I was black good for us
everything because a lot of the things
I've happened to me haven't been because
of my race has been because of my gender
and I am very much aware of because of
the fact that I'm African and direct
like first-generation African born that
for me I did not identify as black I did
not go through a lot of the prejudice a
lot of people did and I came from a
country where like you know that my
privilege and my my family meant that I
like you know you were from a wealthy
back yeah yeah so I did it so a
privileged background which when we lost
everything I became refugees we still
had aspirations so I didn't struggle
with identity as much as like a lot of
people that whose families came came
here from from the Caribbean or to
heritage women who grew up in white
working-class areas who kind of was
basically saw their brothers and their
fathers and all these kind of thing
struggles so it was really difficult
when I start talking about FGM as though
it was like oh you're basically bringing
stigma and shining a light on her
already marginalized community I would
intervene we should like let the white
guy like you know define us because
everyone like the police were seen as a
white institution the government was
seen as a white institution and me
working with them both very closely and
actually really saying that guys you
need to protect me was seen as something
well something that's kind of a sellouts
and I just thought like we're never in a
country I've seen countries fall apart
and fundamentally what what people
wanted to after you get dictatorships
and all these thing is to really bring
back justice and really ensure the rule
of law and I quite like the police I was
it doesn't mean that like you know I'm
not gonna complain as a taxpayer about
the police's system but I did actually
walk around every day thinking the Oh
police officers are racist and a chip on
my shoulder yeah and I don't think like
you know all white men are bad so and I
just think that was that was just a
weird thing for me to be saying as to
them as a black woman and I was just
saying it as a woman and as somebody who
understood the need you know that need
of like you know the criminal justice
system to understand
you know diversity and people like me
[Music]
it's interesting that you bring up this
idea of the being outspoken in this way
and tackling that issue and working with
the white Polly inverted commas for
listeners white police and white
government or whatever it made you kind
of a bit like a traitor I said what does
that I don't know if that's the right
word and one of the reasons we wanted to
talk to is we read an article here oh I
think it was in telegraph around the
time the Boris Johnson then newly minted
prime minister by time this goes out
just the day before the big Saturday or
whatever it's called super super
Saturday is less like proper American
like super Monday to whatever anyway he
appointed a cabinet that had a strong
representation from different ethnic
minority groups the son of a former
Pakistani bus driver people from
different communities from all around
the world black James cleverly you know
brown etc yeah and within an hour a lot
of these people on the left like what's
a carry an Mendoza whatever her name
from the canary came out he's blocked me
she said like you know a preemptive
strike she is editor of the canary and
she came out and said that these are not
people of color they are tone carts of
color and this idea that a person whose
skin is different has just to white has
to think exactly the same way as every
other person whose skin is not white
isn't that the most racist idea that you
could have yeah there was a there was a
lecturer I think she was at Cambridge or
somewhere and I was like so while she
wants to intellectually masturbate over
issues like FGM and all these things
that activist actually get [ __ ] done but
yeah it is it is the whole point of the
fact that privilege is a massive thing
and I think I come and the irony is that
I come from the certain kinds of
privileges that all these people do but
I try to use that privilege in order to
change the world for other people and I
know like so
Priti Patel is
ugandan so she's an East African Indian
the most successful diaspora outside the
Jewish - globally in the UK so she's the
most of the most successful espera and
the fact that she's the Home Secretary
says a testament to a lot of the people
that came here as refugees like my
parents say actually we're not gonna
give up we're gonna suck up and we're
gonna make sure that our children
succeed the idea when you when your
parents come don't necessarily come from
something that they haven't lost
anything and I don't I don't I don't
want to knock them for being like you
know not having a lot of aspirations and
then getting pissed off for people like
me actually delivering two things but it
is offensive it's the whole point of the
fact that I've got young other - like in
a Somali black young boys who are my
cousin's they go to one of the best
schools in like one of the best grammar
schools in London in Crete and who in
Elizabeth and they're in like in a
bonnet and the irony is about 90% of our
school is either African or Sri Lankan
and as a massive issue why that is
because those people all come from
people who had to leave and be forced
out by people who write the canary or
regional areas that they have so the
thing is I've seen the concept of
socialism I've seen the concepts of
communism and I know they don't do any
favors for people like me so they
specifically don't do anything for women
and they don't do anything like
specifically for women so yeah it's like
it is I don't know I'm not like these
people just like ridiculous I'm not sure
about no I'm not I'm not offended by
them and I'm not hurt by them any more
because I think I've got enough clout
now just to kind of to laugh it off but
I think it does hurt a lot of other
young people who want to be able to
identify in a certain political and with
a certain political party or have
certain views and I think I was
privileged enough to be able to do that
I grew up under the new labor and kind
of party and and I am under the January
I am from the generation that things can
only get better and for me things can
only get better under the Conservative
Party right now do I believe in every
single policy because every party has no
do I feel safe under the conservative
party that I do with labor with Jeremy
Corbyn yes so like like you know it's
freedom of speech or freedom of choice
and you believe in democracy then
everybody should be able to have their
democracy but I think the left want you
to stay poor and they want you to stay
black and the idea the fact that you
might be a black person actually it must
be paid yourself and does something they
find really problematic like that is
that is racism that they would rather my
young cousins were all going to [ __ ]
state school in the area that was
probably labor held and then then
pointing to the government at the time
Jake look what you're doing to young
black boys when I actually to be fair
everywhere else failing in this country
is to do with labor has nothing to do
with the Conservative Party ideally and
the places are quite successful here in
in parts of London where it's Labor held
a lot of the people that are there have
turned the local schools into like you
know selection schools like my auntie
can't move to crouch end to a good state
school because of like the house of
prices in London so why shouldn't she
send her children to a Grammar School
means the fact that they can do as well
as some of the people in the Labour
Party's [ __ ] bench at the moment I
think that's the I think that's the
problem so yeah I just I don't really
know how to answer that other than
saying it's quite ridiculous and it's it
is racist it is offensive and people
like the canary don't actually have
don't actually really want like you know
anything to really change for like the
poorest country and the poorest people
in this country and the thing that
always shocked me and we had a former
guest of ours called zubi he was a
rapper and an entrepreneur and
incredibly intelligent man and he was
talking about what you were talking but
the thing that he was talking about as
well and that I never notice is that
they use racist language against you in
order to attack you which I and then say
that they're not racist yeah but that's
what I've said about Jacob I'm saying
that some example Jacob Riis smoke will
not be allowed to say the sort of things
that I get like somebody from the left
is able to say to me so I leave Jasper
called me publicly on on on Twitter a
[ __ ] up Negro what [ __ ] up [ __ ] for
aligning myself with the Tory Party a
lot of my side was hurtin
politicians and people who I personally
know and I personally worked with and
that he tweeted after that say like you
know black face white soul
he's a mixed-race guy I might come on me
like you know I'm actually and this idea
of blackness I just I don't get the idea
of blackness I'm like I'm African I was
born in the continent of Africa I was
raised by great African leaders like
like [ __ ] you I'm black I don't need to
I don't need to like you know search for
my blackness it's something that's that
I've inherited something that I know and
because of that privilege and again this
is the thing why I don't really come at
them as much because I know the
privilege area is to know from the land
you're sourced in and to know the people
and to know your lineage and to know
your history and obviously like you know
slavery and a lot and a lot of I could
pass issue of this country I am this
this country in this world is like it or
links to that but the idea of the fact
that you are manipulating your political
identity through actually textbooks that
weren't even written by people like you
so he will he'll quotes like Malcolm X
and I was like but that's an African
American political leader in a context
when it's about America and racism and
the conversations around in America but
I cannot when it comes to UK that's
completely different when it comes to
Africa it's completely different so I
think what we've done is we've taken a
very political conversation from America
which actually it's fundamental dare to
talk about race and diversity and what
it is to be American
then it is here in the UK and this idea
of the fact that you have to be like a
stay black stay woke all right what the
[ __ ] was I ever mean like stay black
stay woken like I don't understand what
that means like you know the fact that
you know I got a well or is a incredible
the one of the first queens of of the
world and she was ruling in I cannot in
the place of my birth it's like so I
don't need to go to the British Museum
to learn about my history I would like
to claim some of my British Museum so I
think you and every Miss I get misplaced
in the sense that I don't agree with
[ __ ] like that I don't agree with the
British Museum assuming that it's the
hub of culture and can be like you know
on world history
I don't agree with all those things that
are like you know I want us to be able
to protect like you know Timbuktu and
actually ensure that Mali as a country
stays together because like you know
history is that it's four thousand years
old I think one of the interesting
things the ice estate which might be
controversial is as they started blowing
up like these incredible like you know
historical sites is the fact that they
showed that the enlightenment-era did
not start in the 17th century see I
fight things like that when I'm what I'm
talking to my white very intellectual
friends I have died have real dialogue
and real conversations of I said
actually the Enlightenment did not start
in the 17th century the Africa and the
Middle East India or like you know in
Elisha and doing these things just cause
you got discuss you stop using a horse
and cart and start again some
electricity that did not make you the
kings of the world but they wrote
history so that's those words all those
things I'm very much aware of when I
have those conversations but you know I
just I don't have time to be like you
know changing my name to some like you
know Egyptian like you know God and
pretending that I can go get in some
tattoos honest is really ridiculous like
you know the Guardian soulmate is also
the worst place for that [ __ ] as well
God is always the most racist place on
the planet
really I'm I've met 45 year old white
men from NW 5 with tattoos of Africa I
thought do you actually think that's ok
and he's like yeah I really feel at home
in Africa and I'll say you know what I'm
gonna get a tattoo of the Lake District
cuz I love the Lake District so yeah
there was a moment I don't mind people
appreciate in Africa but I feel at home
in Africa jerk and I guys been to Africa
oh yeah he loves African music this kind
of like real feta sized nation I would
say to people I would say to a lot of
these men
I'm as exotic as a banana I don't grow
in this country but you can buy me in
Tesco's I don't come to me and try to
get yourself to be like a little bit
more like you know like FNX eyes like
you know my my ethnicity it's something
that I'm very comfortable with but it's
not something like I don't walk around
with head wraps like when I walk are you
might fall on a head crap is because I'm
having a bad hair day and people think
I'm making a political statement mmm
I really I'm not making a political
statement I'm like you know if I put on
some massive hoop earrings
I'm not making a work political
statement I just can't find anything
else to wear today so there's like it's
been really interesting being me someone
who's very comfortable in my identity
but also like if even me open my mouth
always becomes a political thing and
it's interesting that you say that
because we tend to think of a lot of
black people as being you know towards
labour and leaning towards lifts but if
you look at a lot of people who are
first-generation second-generation
immigrants number one they're very
aspiration they moved to another country
were Tibetan themselves they're very
family orientated they tend to be
incredibly religious as well in socially
conservative and socially conservative I
mean those are all qualities of being on
the right I may well not the right see I
don't I just left them right now to
[ __ ] but just like just not be in
labor not just be not being around I
think that's why that's one of the
things that a lot of people don't get
why Boris one two terms in London he one
two terms in London was lunders very
African and the African Diaspora
identified with him a lot he does quite
well really yeah because the African
diaspora in London identifies with Boris
Johnson if you like parents if you like
in it so not the young Woking so you
won't ask about like this if you anyway
anybody under the age of 25 probably not
bought a beer a beer and beyond that
definitely and I think that it's one of
the things is that the largest
population of black people in the UK the
moment is of African direct descendants
and that's a massive coup for the
Conservative Party if they want to go
into that so they've already good this
is why the difference between the Indian
diaspora and the Pakistani aspera the
Indian diaspora is always very much
voted within the Conservative Party
because of that whole point of
aspiration a lot of the Pakistani
community that have come over here I
like you know we're not were were were
people to work in the mills and certain
places so they've always stayed in
labour areas and kind of than those
other kind of conversations a lot of
them in Scotland have now gone towards
the SNP ironically but ultimately the
African diaspora is very conservative
and they are very aspirational either
all come under especially when it comes
with Jeremy Corbyn they've all fled
countries where the ideas of socialism
czar he's selling at the moment have
actually crushed their consonants so not
that I work for the Conservative Party
or not like you know but I think I can
oh like they would do really well and
everything of black MP we in the
Conservative Party's African never sees
that like every black
because everybody's African that's
interesting that's very interesting
James cleverly Sierra Leonean
interesting oh wow I never ever thought
about where people come from but that's
why I mean and I think that's what I
mean about like cultural identity and
conversations and the whole point is
just because you become poor become a
refugee thism and so my life was a
little bit like coming to America but
the other way around I finally think I'm
here looking for glycan a bride we were
but we deal still it was like my mother
was still turn up as though she like
entitled to the same [ __ ] she did
when I have family around the country
most of my like you know childhood from
the age of like 9 to about 15
translating for several people within
the community because there was no built
in mechanisms for things like you know
translation stuff with a with an NHS so
I I saw that cultural kind of thing or
like you know these Somalis like you
know walking in to places
expecting things and these white people
what are you talking about
I won't have to explain to somebody
there's a term is somebody called Huck
means I have a right to I said in the UK
on entitlements everything you have for
a right to is given to you as a
democracy feel [ __ ] form for
everything as a sea of you are it's like
if you're entitled to it so this idea
I've got right to something doesn't
exist because you have an entitlement to
anything that you haven't already got so
someone with this kind of aspirational
mindset which you clearly have that
comes from a community and a family that
has the aspirational mind says that you
talk about how do you feel about the new
work left and this idea that everybody
is a victim of life I mean you you by
all standards could definitely say
you've been a victim yeah I would say I
would say to people don't try to out
talking to me I mean you somebody like
you say you FGM survivor you refugees
name
black you know yeah you're I mean you're
[ __ ] winning that person I don't like
you know that doesn't that doesn't
define me know those things define me
but they do they do kind of inform a lot
of the things and they of course I do
but what I'm asking is like
indoctrinating people who may have very
different types who may grow up being
poor who may grow up you know as you say
a marginalized community a community
that does have issues with the police
and the criminal justice system which
which are real right
but the indoctrination of people with
this victimhood mentality I don't
imagine you're a fan of that no I'd also
I do I'm not a victim of like you know
counseling people or not being able to
communicate with people so there's I
cannot always having a conversation with
somebody on the other side and it's
always easy for me to cross over like if
I met somebody that was like fascists or
a neo-nazi or whatever I it would be
easy for me to cross over then it would
be easy for them to cross over to and
have a conversation with me because my
whole point is that I'm comfortable in
my identity and I want to have a
conversation with you doesn't mean we
have to get along at the end of the day
and I remember there was one of my one
of my this kid I was a union with wonder
stand as a counselor and he sent me an
email like you know if I can a few
months ago and he said oh you know while
one song as a counselor but no people
making issues about things I wrote
because they said that I was because I
was racist I said but Dinah you are
racist and it's okay for you my friend
I'm like yeah I'm a just because you are
black Somali friend there's not making
not erasing we have these conversations
all the time I'm not and I said
technically everybody is a racist but it
depends on what you do with that bias on
that prejudice so it's it's harder it
informs you and I said what I write
about the fact that you are I can a
suitable for a certain position like in
a you could probably two years and your
band you have biases the I joke thing
like that you will use as I can approach
this against people within those
communities yes I would but I will not
stand here and say that you're not a
racist and it takes a lot of people
you're basically trying to get a racist
to like that's
but yeah but the whole point is what I
say like you know that I can Oh what is
your what is the bar for you not to be a
race like you know if did you ever use
to anywhere did you ever black black up
whatever it is it's like all those
things you know there are races and
stupid things to do but does that mean
that you're not necessarily a person I
could do a job and a person that like
you know has redeemed themselves
probably does and so there's so that we
we make racist decisions on a day-to-day
basis like my other side you know the
whole thing is like who you date who
you're attracted to what you eat where
you live all those things are things
that ultimately are based on your biases
are uncertain you know faith religions
or class or whatever it is but does that
mean that you're a horrible person
I don't think so because I don't know
you so that's so I'm I'm of that people
that I came like you know I saw the
results of a civil war that was all
about tribalism and I try not to like
you know say somebody can be a hundred
percent of one thing - why what's that
guy from the EDL would I want to be
friends with him not really probably but
it's just small because he's probably a
[ __ ] I supposed to be like whatever
he bangs on about about race and stuff
he's just like he's just a very insecure
man so I think we do live in a world
where complexity is not respected and I
grew up in a world where complexity was
respected and where you like you know
had conversations with people rather
seeking perfection because I think if
you're trying to be perfect if you try
to have these conversations then you're
probably floating you're probably hiding
something hmm and yes you talked about
tribalism and it's such a good point you
they become more tribal as a society now
yeah yeah definitely that's why I stood
for the women's equality party in 2017
and it was like I'm gonna be Labor
you're like this and I was like but this
is not about tribes or politics or - you
what are you voting for in terms of
policies and things like that and for me
I think that's what really freaks me on
and that's what it's like you know
corrosive is this is the tribalism which
ironically comes more from like when I
vote to the Labor Party when I voted for
the Labor Party which I actually did in
every single general election of my life
like you know nobody from that like no
conservative or no Lib Dem or Green
Party member or whatever said to me oh
you're a [ __ ] wanker like [ __ ] you
you label voting they can't
I say like you know I voted the
Conservative Party in the marrow
elections are you [ __ ] Tory and I was
thinking like what like like why are you
not entitled to her opinion to say the
other thing say I'm gonna fight you I'm
gonna like you know argue against you
I'm gonna win the seats but this idea of
the fact that there is only one answer
to the whole world it's actually quite
problematic and I think so my brother's
standing for the Conservative Party in
Cardiff North it's a boy called another
African if he wins for Somalia so yeah
but but the whole thing is like I think
politics is a personal thing and it does
change and if you don't if your politics
hasn't evolved since you were 16 then
it's something wrong with you yeah it's
interesting you talk about the this I
mean these super tolerant people it's
amazing how quickly they become
incredibly intolerant yeah once they
find out that you don't agree with them
on every single tiny little thing yeah I
haven't forbade the fact that I think
the Tories are okay and I believe in the
existence of the State of Israel
it's actually it's quite it's I think
and also it's it's very much anti
intellectual I think that is the problem
is the fact that we've now just got
shouting heads from both sides and none
of it is informed and none of it it's
like I have opinions like on different
things like you know I believe in
taxation I believe in the NHS I believe
in like you know if you were to do
private education fight there are things
I believe in which my people said you
are you so right-wing understand okay
what on a spectrum of things I believe
in like what is actually right-wing
above about that I'm offering the fact
that I do actually believe that if you
go to action emergency more than twice
in 18 months with an injury that was
caused because you were drunk you should
do some community service
[Laughter]
me because it allowed to get drunk but
all I think that you don't actually
control your ass massage you terrible
accident mergency and I was giving this
advice to the doctor and he just looks
at me say that you are you mental it's
like I'm just saying like you know I did
that NHS should be more about preventing
these things rather than cure like you
know me actually turning up then I got a
call the next day from the hospital
asking me how likely I would be to
recommend the role free for a family
member in the same situation as like I
don't want to have an asthma attack so
what kind of so they wanna do customer
engagement so the NHS not does customer
engagement callbacks now you talk about
that you voted for conservatives in the
mare election and I'm genuinely
interested to hear your point of view
because we talk a lot about how Boris
Johnson is seen as a problematic figure
you know he makes jokes about you know
women Muslim women looking like
letterboxes what is your opinion of him
and do you think that he should be
allowed to make those jokes do you think
he should apologize yeah I think either
not talk about that but ultimately I
hate he's the Prime Minister I think the
Prime Minister deserves respect and I do
I think he for me I've worked at them
personally and I and I know his personal
commitments to to to the country on two
issues that I really want to and kind of
I'm kind of talk about but ultimately is
the same thing with the same thing with
Jeremy Corbyn I don't like him but I
still respect him as a leader of the
Opposition I think we've got this point
where we've demonized people so much for
even having an opinion or saying
anything that it's so there was an
interesting take they asked a guy who
was is it Abdul from Bristol they asked
Abdul for Bristol of egg to ask the
leaders a question when there was when
there was the stuff about the
Conservative Party leadership I'm like a
blue from Bristol is more problematic to
women like me then the the work people
that want to have issues around Boris
Johnson and all these things I'm nobody
nobody read nobody that was throwing up
arms and having these conversations
actually read the full article about his
his fundamental principles of saying
that women should be able to choose to
wear what they want to wear
but then they'll defend someone like
Abdul who he'll probably call me a [ __ ]
and want me to be like you know I cannot
hung up by my neck for not wearing a
headscarf so I wanna say to the left
like you know who do you actually stand
is our Diaries because I Muslim
feminists have been complaining about
the burger for a long time I just I'd
literally I don't talk but I just don't
get this whole defense of the burqa it's
like it's a it's it's a it's problematic
there is no choice in it and people that
wear the burqa have chosen a political
ideology is it's a political is a
political thing so they've taken a
political standpoint against the
fundamental democracies in this country
they won't live in a country where the
work is enforced and weather and
everything to do with the burkas
respecting because they know as women in
those countries that they'll have no
rights so it's just like so for someone
like me the burkas problematic for
someone like me white walk people
protecting the burqa when they're not
going to be subjected to a problematic
it's [ __ ] ironic one white feminist
lesbian protect one just to protect the
burqa the interests of not getting sued
under libel laws all three of us should
acknowledge that we have no evidence
that Abdul from would call you hung up
by the neck people I would not wish to
speculate so Cage for example who this
kind of extreme is male organization I
don't want to call them Muslim
organization because a lot of the things
that they protect are very masculine
Muslim like things about masculinity and
misogyny they would want to defend the
burger but people are like gonna go yeah
ask age of said okay just said I'm like
forgot to say like the name is case cuz
they wanna do they want a cage women so
it's like so there is it's more
problematic like when I was talking
about after when I was talking about FGM
white men winning the conservative party
understood and respected and were like
this is horrible what we're doing men
from my own community and from these
other kind of very I get over SMI
like in a very traditional communities
or very patriotic communities who all
wanted to have me killed and several did
trying to kill me so I think like if the
biggest issue that you've got is
somebody saying something about a
letterbox then you're not then you're
not actually really talking to Muslim
women who are dealing with the
consequences of of the narrow
interpretation of Islam and one of the
things about and one of the things about
the growth in Islamophobia and these
kind of country and these kind of things
are it's so it's always happened there's
like massive tensions within poor white
working-class communities where a lot of
these extremist views are being held and
then you've got these ginger jihadis as
I like to call them who like you know
white men who all of a sudden like you
know convert to Islam think they know
better than me and start going down to
the local corner shop and asking for
pork to be banned
I've called Peter peep ok we're gonna
still having issues with you know people
saying pork should we plan our course
should be banned and all these other
kind of things but that is not what
tolerant Islam or conversations have
been about so I think we need to look at
where the conversations around the
so-called definitions of Islamophobia
come from because I think silencing
women like me you say we don't like to
poke her polygamy is wrong like you know
all these things we should be protected
as like you know identities of being
Muslim I think that would be fighting
about in all these countries that we all
come from so yeah I think it's right I
think there's a massive issue around who
were targeting around the the growth of
Islamophobia and I think a lot of that
has to sit with a lot of the man who's
become the kind of the gatekeepers of
these communities but it's a very good
point the reason I made the thing about
libel is because a few weeks ago we were
talking about Amazon on your show and
Frances insinuated that they may not pay
as much tax as they should okay and some
of our viewers who are lawyers email
then going you may want to look up libel
laws guys so I did look up libel laws
and basically if you say anything on our
show that turns out to be inaccurate
well just think I do think it's just one
of those things that nobody is calling
up like you know leaders or certain
communities but that's a totally
different point you're entitled to make
I'm making but Abdul from Bristol we
just want to say we've run out of time
unfortunately it's been a great
interview thank you sir coming we have
got one final question for you which is
what is the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be talking about in
society that we should be talking about
obviously I want every Chinese were not
talking about enough about vaginas I
mean and as a consultation at the moment
Alto surrogacy I think we should
actually talking more about like you
know the toxic nurse of surrogacy within
our society right now and I think this
idea of the fact of like you know having
your own designer babies and kind of
assuming that everybody has the right
type of child a bit random but it's not
running I just I'm really not you know
there was a show that I watched a few
years ago which had these like you know
like this family that was buying eggs
from like white hot women and then going
to India and just pumping their eggs and
their sperm like these these fetuses
into these poor the these poor twins in
women and there are enough kids out
there for us to adopt about this idea of
the fact that we're all doing i
surrogacy as though because it's or this
is a new way that technology has allowed
us to have a family it's really
problematic and i think and then again
you can't say that because it's about
certain communities fear like they've
been and they're being targeted but i
just thing like you know surrogacy is a
massive issue and i think it's a I think
it's a very and like in a research and
talked about form of violence case women
alright well thanks for bringing it up
as always follow our guest name Co on
Twitter we'll put a link out to that and
follow us and we will see you in a week
from now with another brilliant episode
take care see you next week guys thanks
for watching guys as always subscribe to
the YouTube channel click the bell
button next to subscribe button so you
get notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word